it's about 8 000 internally displaced
syrians living near the Jordanian border
have just received much needed
humanitarian supplies this was the first
delivery of Aid in more than a year
u.s-based non-governmental agency called
the Syrian emergency task force
organized the effort with support from
the U.S military Syrian government and
Russian forces have surrounded the camp
since 2019 accusing its residents of
supporting anti-government Fighters they
have also prevented un Aid deliveries
Mustafa is the executive director of the
Syrian emergency task force and joins us
from Washington D.C great to have you
with us it sounds like this has been a
desperate or still is a desperate
situation for people living in this Camp
what Aid have you managed to take in
what was needed
so since the Inception in 2014 of this
Camp they've lived under the protection
of being within the 55 kilometer zone of
the International Coalition next to an
International Coalition Garrison and
with U.S partner forces there but they
have been besieged as you mentioned and
it's been a desperate situation The
Siege continues by Russia Iran and the
Assad regime but we've already delivered
thank god with the support of the US
military on available space for ongoing
operations diverting no resources or
funding from the US government we've
been able to bring in seeds wheat seeds
vegetable and fruit seeds and irrigation
equipment things that can help them
sustain themselves and we are planning
on on bringing in much more Aid that
that has that we're procuring and then
sending over so it's it's uh one for for
once a story of a good story out of Rook
ban and the people on the ground deserve
all the education food medical needs the
the that they need
um and hopefully we'll be able to help
continue to do that it is a good story
it does also raise some questions as to
why the U.S military stepped in now to
help
well I would just say first of all the
United States has always been calling
for cross line and cross-border Aid uh
in turukbang Camp and until other
internally displaced uh persons camp but
as we all know uh Russia the Assad
regime Iran
um have all prevented both crossline and
cross-border Aid when they can and the
problem is the process that the United
States the rest of the International
Community has been relying on is the UN
you know the U.N process to bring Aid to
this camp but this U.N process based in
Damascus the U.N Damascus office is
under essentially control of the Assad
regime and so relying on a process to
break a siege that has the veto power of
the people that are implementing The
Siege like Russia and Iran uh has been
the issue for so many years and what
happened about really you know a couple
of years ago is we identified a way that
an NGO and the American people and
whoever donates uh to to this non-profit
American organization found a legal way
to be able to utilize something called
the Dentin program which allows us to
use based on available space for ongoing
operations U.S military transport and we
have we you know can't thank enough uh
you know the the Department of Defense
uh through oir for supporting this
process and again uh it's something that
at the end of the day is I'm grateful
personally for the American people those
that have donated to sctf to be able to
do this uh and you know it's just now
that we've been able to to make this
breakthrough and I hope this uh can
bring about a more sustainable solution
where the UN does deliver Aid where the
bordering countries do open their
borders but until that day comes the
people of Rickman deserve support and
the Syrian emergency task force the
people of the United States those who
also support us are committed to that
for the long term well one wonders what
the reaction of the Syrian regime and
others that support it will be because
the your organization and with the
support of the US military is
effectively broken The Siege that the
Assad Government tried to impose on
Rockburn
that's absolutely right not just the
asset government the Assad government
Russia and Iran and iranian-backed
militias that are in a region that
surround the camp not to mention uh Arab
countries within the Arabic that are
normalizing with Assad uh as well that
do not allow you know cross-border Aid
despite all of that we're able to do
this and in terms of the reaction well
let's just look at the actions today
today as I'm sitting talking to you the
Russian Air Force is killing civilians
there have been massacres committed over
the last 24 hours by Russia these lives
of these children men women they're no
less human than our brothers and sisters
being killed by the same Russian forces
in Ukraine and and this is the reaction
we're seeing a continued decision in
Russian Air Force and Assad regime
bombardment of civilians in Syria while
American military planes working with an
NGO are providing Aid to a a campuses by
them Let's uh not to take take away from
the fact that it is a good day that
people there have got Aid thanks very
much for joining us from Washington DC